jur dizaines de milliards issus du
trafic de stupéfiants ont été absorbés
par un certain nombre de banques aux
états unis qui d'ailleurs ont été
poursuivis en justice et ont payé des
amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 15 avril à une
réouverture des terrasses et des lieux
culturels à la mi mai est ce possible
dans quelles conditions le chef de
l'état et les ministres réunis en ce
moment depuis 18h sur ce sujet la france
qui franchit ce soir officiellement un
cap funeste celui des cent mille morts
dus qu'aux vie d'emmanuel macron la
firme nous n'oublierons aucun visage
aucun ans le gouvernement promet un
hommage aux victimes certaines familles
le souhaitent d'autres non estimant que
l'exécutif est responsable en partie de
la situation moscou promettent une
réponse inévitable réaction à la série
de nouvelles sanctions financières
décrétée à son encontre par washington
les états unis annoncent également
l'expulsion de diplomates russes un tel
comportement agressif recevra une forte
réponse déclare la diplomatie russe
[Musique]
les discussions sur le nucléaire iranien
ont repris à vienne aujourd'hui dans un
climat tendu malgré une impression
générale positive selon un diplomate
russe
joe biden avait promis durant la
campagne de revenir dans l'accord
dénoncé par son prédécesseur mais la
récente actualité au moyen-orient a
ravivé les tensions autour du programme
atomique de terrain
[Musique]
emmanuel macron il est ministre réunit
donc depuis 18 heures pour discuter des
protocoles de réouverture progressive
des lieux accueillant du public avec un
objectif ambitieux un déconfinement mi
mai pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite en direct de
l'elysée ben hassen chébili bonsoir
bassem la réunion est toujours en cours
c'est bien ça effectivement c'est fini
la réunion est toujours en cours
au menu des discussions le protocole de
réouverture qu'avait annoncé et promis
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il avait annoncé
cet 3 ce troisième confinement sur
l'ensemble du territoire la réunion est
toujours en cours à l'elysée autour d'
emmanuel macron beaucoup de ses
ministres notamment le ministre de
l'emploi de la santé du tourisme de
l'économie ou encore gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur objectif établir
le calendrier et les protocoles pour
sortir de cette situation sur ces
situations qu'on en vit actuellement est
surtout destiné à ces lieux qui
reçoivent énormément de public le chef
de l'état a déclaré pendant cette
réunion que les ouvertures se feront de
manière progressive en respectant un
protocole assez strict il a eu un mot
bien sûr pour la culture il a dit que la
culture sera la haye dès la première
phase une première phase qui devra durer
notamment deux à trois semaines si cela
fonctionne bien sûr nous passerons sur
la deuxième phase l'objectif bien sûr de
l'ensemble du gouvernement c'est de
donner de la cohérence à l'ensemble et
surtout à leur programme une réunion qui
intervient après que les différents
ministres et heureux rencontrés et a
visité certains de ces acteurs qui sont
pénalisés par cette fermeture qui dure
près d'un an notamment les gens de la
culture ou encore de la restauration le
chef de l'état compte bien tenir ses
promesses à savoir cette ouverture
prévue à partir de mi-mai et pour cela
ils tablent sur cette vaccination en
accélérant cette vaccination qui a déjà
commencé avec les différents vaccins
disponibles sur l'ensemble du territoire
les plus de 65 ans déjà commencé et jean
castex le premier ministre a même
annoncé qu'à partir du week-end prochain
les policiers et les enseignants de plus
de 55 ans pourront aussi être vaccinés
ce sont au total plus de 430 mille
professionnels de ces
deux fonctions qui seront concernées par
ces deux vaccinations sème la journée
marquée par un triste record celui des
cent mille personnes décédées du code
vide
[Musique]
effectivement c'est fanny cette réunion
intervient alors qu'aujourd'hui en
france on a dépassé le cap des cent
mille victimes du cobp idées pour être
plus près 600 milles et cinq victimes
300 victimes de puces
aujourd'hui la france rejoint notamment
ses deux voisins européens la
grande-bretagne et l'italie qui
comptabilise 127000 et 115 mille décès
un hommage national sera peut être
donnée c'est en tout cas ce qu'avait
annoncé à gabriel atta le porte parole
du gouvernement
une idée qui est sorti en conseil des
ministres et que le chef de l'état est
plutôt favorable à m déclarait que
personne ne sera oublié
écoutez le chef de l'état depuis le
début de la pandémie
cent mille françaises et français ont
succombé au virus
nous avons tous une pensée pour leurs
familles leurs proches pour les enfants
qui ont perdu un parent ou un grand
parent les fratries endeuillé les
amitiés faucher et si toute notre
énergie est aujourd'hui tournée vers la
sortie de cette épreuve
nous n'oublierons aucun visage aucun
le gouvernement a donc promis un cane
hommage national pour l'ensemble des
victimes du corona à virus sans donner
de date exacte compte à cette horde de
sauvages ils pouvaient rejoindre la
longue liste des pays qui ont déjà rendu
hommage à leurs victimes à savoir la
suisse ou encore la chine le royaume uni
si beaucoup sont favorables à cette cet
hommage national d'autres notamment des
associations sont contre cet hommage et
demande au chef de l'état de prendre ses
responsabilités
certaines associations notamment corona
victime ou encore collectif 6 94 71
demande au delà de cet hommage que je
n'y ai manuel macron reconnaisse sa
responsabilité face aux nombres de morts
quoique lui la france face à ce qu un
virus
merci bfm chez billes en direct de
l'elysée derrière ce chiffre symbolique
des cent mille morts ce sont des vies
brisées de milliers de familles qui ont
perdu un proche
certains d'entre elles certaines d'entre
elles n'ont même pas pu faire un dernier
adieu à lionel petit par président de
l'association victimes du coc vide 19
nous libres nous livre ce soir son
témoignage
bonsoir ionel à petits pas merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france vous avez donc perdu votre
épouse du coc vide et vous allez nous en
parler dans quelques instants de ces
circonstances difficiles mais tout
d'abord ce tweet ce soir il ya quelques
minutes d' emmanuel macron nous
n'oublierons qu'un visage aucun nom
alors que la france donc a franchi ce
cap de 200 mille morts votre réaction
tout d'abord bonsoir merci de me
recevoir sur votre chaîne en préambule
je voudrais préciser que mon nez à plus
de cent mille morts depuis un certain
temps parce que dans ce chiffre ne sont
pas comptabilisées les personnes
décédées ducobu à domicile ma réaction
par rapport à ce qu'a dit le président
ce soir écouter
je commence à me réjouir un peu de cette
position puisque ça fait quand même 1
nord est et quatre courriers qu'on lui
envoie pour être reçus par lui pour
pouvoir justement discuter de cet
hommage et de quel type dommage on va
mettre en place parce que derrière le
mouvement
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il entend moi
je souhaite maintenant qu'ils nous qui
nous contactent et qu'on se rend compte
assez rapidement pour échanger et ont
regardé ces propositions examinées les
notes et puis je pense que entre gens
intelligents de trouver un compromis
dans l'ensemble vous allez justement
nous raconter évidemment les
circonstances dans lesquelles vous avez
perdu votre épouse mais clairement
aujourd'hui pour vers faire votre deuil
vous avez besoin d'entendre ces mots de
la part du chef de l'état ça vous
apaiserait d'une certaine manière oui le
lot main jeu
enfin moi j'ai toujours dit que
l'hommage ne ferait pas le deuil bien
sûr que le deuil est toujours difficile
à faire même au bout d'un an
vu les circonstances dans lesquelles nos
proches sont partis mais mais c'est une
étape qui va nous permettre de faire le
deuil
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
hormis que le président de la république
prend la parole c'est aussi le père de
la nation et dans ce cadre là c'est la
nation qui rend un hommage aux personnes
décédées de la coke et 19 et c'est
également pour le rendre ce respect
cette dignité et cette reconnaissance
dont ils ont tant manqué dans les phases
que l'on a connu des premières vagues
notamment
c'est vrai qu'à l'occasion de voile à ce
funeste chiffres en cent mille victimes
ducobu dont on a entendu tout au long de
la journée beaucoup de témoignages très
difficile on se rend compte peut-être de
choses ça nous saute à la figure si
j'ose dire souvent des familles qui
n'ont pas pu dire adieu à leurs proches
c'est votre cas lionel petit pas oui
tout à fait c'est bon comme et moi comme
d'autres vous savez mon épouse est parti
le 23 mars à 1h du matin dans
l'ambulance et je ne les ai plus jamais
revu ni vivante ni des saintes donc donc
voilà d'autres personnes passaient alors
écoutez mon épouse a présenté un épisode
de fièvre vers 11 heures 11 heures du
soir 3 heures et est donc on a remis le
réveil à une heure du matin pour
regarder un peu la situation si elle se
ranger et bien entendu elle s'était
plutôt dégradée qu'autre chose et on
faisait appel à lui le samu est venue la
chercher et elle est partie à l'hôpital
- elle m'a fait un petit coucou de la
main à travers les villes comme je
disais précédemment jeux les plus jamais
revu ni vivante et des feintes et
ensuite elle était hospitalisée
deux tests pcr lui ayant été fait s'ils
se sont avérés positifs a été ensuite
placé dans une taie qu'ovide très
rapidement et son état s'est dégradé
très rapidement et donc au bout de six
jours à l'aider à les décider de ce
virus vous nous dites vous ne l'avez
jamais revu ni à l'hôpital ni défunte
vous n'avez pas pu lui rendre visite à
l'hôpital est ce que vous avez essayé de
le faire qu'est ce qu'on vous a répondu
bien sûr
surtout quand il est parti à l'hôpital
les ambulanciers ont bien sûr été pas
pouvoir me répondre mais dans les
entretiens que j'ai eus les jours
suivants avec les médecins j'ai demandé
si je pouvais aller à voir ça m'a été
refusée totalement puisque alitées
atteintes du coc vite donc placé dans
unique et ovide interdiction d'aller la
voir et application des règles et des
protocoles stricts que l'on peut
comprendre à l'époque mais on a tout
simplement oublié dans ces protocoles
qu'on s'occupait du main donc une
inhumanité incroyable à notre époque et
dans une société civilisée comme les
nôtres comment nous a appris son décès
m'a écouté le téléphone a sonné à 6
heures du matin 6h18 du matin le samedi
29 mars j'ai eu au téléphone
une femme médecin qui ne m'a pas informé
de suite de son décès mais timor qui
mardi que la nuit c'était très très mal
passé que son état s'était dégradé pour
finalement dire qu'elle était elle était
décédée très très récemment par rapport
au petit coup de fil qu'elle venait de
le passer à ce moment là on imagine
votre chope bien évidemment vous essayez
peut-être forcément de demander à la
voix votre épouse
bah oui c'est ce que j'ai fais que me
l'avait fait précédemment
et là encore la réponse a été de me dire
mais non monsieur puisqu'elle est décédé
du covin donc un autre dans les
procédures coded est donc vous ne
pourrez pas aller la voir pour aller la
voir alors effectivement vous savez même
dans le cadre date et ses classiques
quand on vous annonce la mort d'un très
proche c'est toujours très difficile
mais nous dans les conditions dans
lesquelles c'est arrivé où on n'a pas pu
aller voir nos défunts on a pas on n'a
plus droit au visage
comme on le lit ça fait partie des
processus et des process qui nous
permette d'aller vers le deuil nous
l'atp vinos ton funéraire on n'avait pas
pu écarter des amis vous n'avez pas pu
faire tout ce temps aucun donc aucun
rite funéraire il faut savoir que toutes
les personnes décédées de lakovic 19 ont
été mis nus dans des housses cents soit
mortuaire certains corps ont été j'avais
lisais je ne sais pas pour mon épouse
mais certains qui ont arrêté j'avais 10
et leus ont été fermées ni dans des
circuits étanche et les cercueils
direction le crématorium et pour
certains sont passés à la crémation très
très rapidement les les mordus qu'ovide
ont été considérés comme des pestiférés
- on les voyait plus il disparaissait et
muse était lyonnais petit pas clairement
parlait de l'hommage du chef de l'état
en ce début d'interview aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous demandez au chef de
l'état des excuses non pas pour la
présence du logo vite parce que ça il
n'y peut rien mais pour ce que vous
venez de nous raconter cette gestion
catastrophique parce que malheureusement
et vous l'avez dit vous n'êtes pas la
première famille à avoir vécu ce
cauchemar
écoutez moi par rapport par rapport à la
responsabilité du chef de l'état moi je
suis président d'une association je ne
suis pas là je ne le ferai pas je ne
suis pas là pour juger de la
responsabilité du chef de l'état dans
notre pays des instances existent pour
ça s'appelle la justice pour celles et
ceux qui désireront chercher une
responsabilité du chef de l'état une
responsabilité éventuelles la justice et
est là pour ça moi je je je suis un
président d'une association qui ne juge
pas qu'ils demandent au chef de l'état
de mettre en place cet hommage pourront
rendre à nos défunts la dignité humaine
le respect et la reconnaissance qu'ils
n'ont pas eue dans le cadre du processus
de leur décès et du deuil accompli par
les familles derrière clairement
aujourd'hui ça sera ma dernière question
quel est votre état d'esprit vous
ressentez
mais j'ai une infime tristesse mais
aussi de la colère c'est les deux cd de
il ya toujours la tristesse même au bout
d'un an
très honnêtement mon deuil est toujours
pas fille je n'arrive pas à le faire ils
ont m'a volé un moment vous savez quand
on m'a annoncé le décès de mon épouse à
6h18 le système à un climat femme elle
ne m'a plus appartenu je n'ai plus eu
mon mot à dire le système m'a pris ma
femme sans que je puisse faire quoi que
ce soit et et en même temps doit être un
peu satisfaction par rapport à ce qu'a
exprimé le chef de l'état on semble
s'orienter quand même dansé dansé dans
cet hommage donc maintenant écouter
comme on dit là bas les dents chef
aidants est dans le camp du chef de
l'état j'ai toujours écrit ai toujours
dit j'ai été à sa disposition quand il
le souhaiterait je le répète encore ce
soir
si quelqu'un longtemps que le message
passe et moi je suis toujours prêt à
échanger avec lui sur les procédures de
cet hommage à mettre en place
merci beaucoup lionel petitpas président
de l'association amitié ducobu 19 merci
de nous avoir livré votre témoignage
si et quand on entend évidemment ce type
de témoignage et avec un bilan funeste
200000 morts et des jours encore
difficiles à venir on se pose évidemment
la question quand je viens de poser
notre invité l'état doit-il s'excuser
les avis semblent partagés c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler
jean pierre pons députée la république
en marche 5e circonscription du pas de
calais bonsoir jean pierre conte merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés stéphane
heures sénateurs rnd bouches-du-rhône
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être sur
notre antenne avant évidemment d'entamer
ce débat le chef de l'état doit-il ou
non s'excuser il a déjà commencé ce soir
avec ce tweet nous n'oublierons aucun
nom aucun visage c'était les mots qu'il
fallait selon vous stéphane ravier les
justes mots nous n'oublierons okamura
n'ont aucun visage ou pas non plus le
nom emmanuel macron edouard philippe du
et olivier ferrand le monsieur castex
n'oublieront pas les cache une haut de
son sable de cette pirouette inter il a
conduit à ce notre pays soit en deuil et
à perdre une cent mille deux cent mille
morts car j'avoue apprendre que les nos
compatriotes qui sont habilités à
domicile ne sont même pas comptabilisés
dans cette statistique est et je pense
aussi aux familles accompagnées de
témoignages poignants de cet époux qui
n'a pas pu accompagner son épouse taipei
ligne magnifique s'est ajoutée à
l'incapacité du gouvernement à contrôler
cette épidémie donc des excuses et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais ça
changera rien dans la sphère le chef de
l'état et le gouvernement et peña peau
gouverner c'est à dire pourquoi il n'en
rien prévu et la catastrophe sanitaire
et là je comprends certaines familles
des excuses moi j'attendais à tous les
âges de sanitaires ou en finir avec
cette catastrophe et qui ne s'en
produise pas d'autres jean-pierre pas
sur ses premiers mots tout d'abord
qu'ils sont
le prémice effectivement comme l'a
promis le gouvernement d'un hommage vous
êtes en phase avec le chef de l'état
nous n'oublierons aucun nom aucun visage
ce sont les mots justes ce soit oui
j'entends les mots justes je pense qu'il
faut penser
bien sûr ceux qui sont décédés mais
aussi à leurs familles familles qui
n'ont pas pu tout à fait faire leur
deuil voir au dernier moment lors leurs
parents décider mais vous pouvez pas
faire autrement
des personnes qui étaient infectées donc
le fait que d'autres personnes puissent
les approcher ça pouvait décontaminer y
avoir de répercussions
je pense aux mages ou y penser à ces
personnes décédées oui comme il faut
penser aussi à roues soignants à tous
ceux qui les ont dû les accompagner même
de façon difficile mais je pense que
tout ce monde là est à mettre en avant
alors avant de vous faire répondre
stéphane ravier je voudrais vous faire
réagir aux propos d'olivier fort le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
qui a des mots durs envers l'exécutif
j'ai l'impression qu'ils emmanuel macron
est dans une forme d'un soutenable
légèreté c'est lui qui a laissé dire par
ses proches qu'il était devenu
épidémiologistes qui l'a laissé entendre
que la science était bien mais que la
politique devait prendre le dessus qu'il
était finalement celui qui savait mieux
que tout le monde
donc oui il a une responsabilité
particulière parce que c'est lui qui a
fait ses choix
c'est vrai que cette responsabilité
particulière même certaines associations
en parlant aujourd'hui disent en
substance il ne faut pas que le chef de
l'état s'excuse parce qu'il a eu une
partie des responsabilités aujourd'hui
clairement c'est votre propos stéphane
ravier serait ou doré une forme
d'indécence à ce que le chef de l'état
s'excuse et légère de l'état au final je
dirais que c'est bien normal c'est lui
qui a pris les décisions le conseil
scientifique s'est prononcé il a émis
des avis et au final c'est le chef de
l'état qui a imposé à tous sa décision
ou ses décisions la réalité
que à chaque fois ils étaient en retard
ou alors ils se trompent et cc c'est la
réalité il s'est trompé en refusant de
fermer les frontières lorsque nous le
demande dieu nous le demandions pardon
en août et le mois de mars l'année
dernière il s'est trompé à la mort
lorsqu'il a participé lui aussi à ne pas
ré équiper l'hôpital comme ils auraient
dû l'être
il s'est trompé en n'ayant pas commandé
les matches qu'il s'est trompé
on ne commande pas aller respirateur
c'est qu'il s'est trompé dans la
commande des vaccins lorsqu'ils à
idéologiquement lorsqu'il s'est mis
alors que de l'union européenne est un
frein à la commande de ces vaccins et
donc à la vaccination mais qu'il se soit
trompé soit était en retard de bout en
bout
il porte donc l'entière responsabilité
de cette gestion entre guillemets de
cette crise sanitaire
j genou je n'imagine pas démissionner
avant les élections présidentielles mais
c'est aux français à se souvenir que
celui qui aurait dû anticiper celui qui
aurait dû protéger et bien à laisser le
peuple français
être le plus exposé quasiment d'europe
et même au delà quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui en france il ya 15 2% de
matinée contre 37% au chili alors je
n'ai aucun mépris pour les chiliens bien
sûr mais quand on on dit que la france
est un pays est l'un des pays les plus
avancés du monde et que l'on est loin
derrière le chili c'est qu'il ya bien un
problème local un problème structurel
dans le chef de l'état porte une lourde
responsabilité en pierre ponce est vrai
que ça revient souvent évidemment
l'écliptique vous l'ignorez pas on en
parle tous les jours partout sur la
gestion de la crise
personne ne dit évidemment que c'est
emmanuel macron qui a porté le coup vite
mais beaucoup critiquent et fustige
sûrement la gestion de la crise
sanitaire du gouvernement que
pouvez-vous répondre à votre adversaire
ce soir quand il fait part de ses
critiques
objectif tout de même mais de toute
façon
l'action du gouvernement depuis le début
critiquer c'est qu'avec les mâles ce que
le confinement la sortie du confinement
les vaccins ces terrasses a toujours été
je ne critique mais aucune opposition de
l'opposition faut pas oublier que cette
maladie ou ne la connaissez pas on ne le
savait pas comment elle allait évoluer
alors prévoir quand on ne connaît pas
d'autant plus que je suis médecin mois
pour tout vous dire qu'en décembre 2019
quand on a commencé à parler du corry
jeu mais qui dit bah ça va être créé et
puis l'on ben je me suis trompé
peut-être même le tout c'est eux par
rapport à ce qui était annoncé subtilité
vu au moins pas au début c'était de
essayer de le contrecarrer
l'évolution de ce virus et je suis sûr
que ya six mois on ne pouvait pas
imaginer cette deuxième phase est lui
encore pensé qu' à ce virus brésilien
qui est en train d'émerger et je pense
qu'il est facile de dire y'a qu'à faut
qu'on
1 mais devant qu'encore une fois de
maladies qui étaient totalement
on ne connaissait pas son évolution on
connaissait pas comment la traiter et on
en a entendu des traitements aussi est
de droite et de gauche mais je pense le
gouvernement a fait au mieux au mieux
par rapport à ce qui lui est arrivé et
il est facile de dire bah oui il fallait
prévoir mais je pense que prévoir le
devant cette maladie
c'était quasiment impossible il a viré
suivant le conseil scientifique
et pourtant lors dans l'hémicycle
j'ai entendu des critiques par rapport
au conseil scientifique en disant ben
oui c'est lui qui dirige la france alors
que le conseil scientifique est là pour
éclairer et de politiques pour décider
et e
quand on regarde le nombre d'avis qu'il
peut y avoir
et un médecin sont entendus de tout de
tout inde et du blanc du moins deux pour
du concours de confrères et même quelque
chose d d d fois absolument et savon
n'oubliez pas qu'au début de l'épidémie
wemmel viser que les masques n'était pas
nécessaire
au tout début alors donc on peut aussi
citer le web est ce qu'elle se soit
trompé mais je pense que le gouvernement
a géré au mieux en fonction de ce qu'il
savait et par rapport aux 6 à la tante
de la population parce qu'il ya le
contexte sanitaire il ya contexte
économique des camarades y est c'est
intéressant nous dit monsieur pons parce
que on dit il a voulu faire trop de
politique mais il a aussi peut-être
essayer de préserver l'économie jusqu'au
bout c'est ce qu'on souhaitait aussi une
partie des français
ce que dit le député du nord la santé
qu'elle est critiquée à l'extériorité
louis du pas de calais ne m'en voulez
pas pour ça ça reste la france ne sont
pas contenté de critiquer a posteriori
et le mois de mars nous avons proposé de
fermer les frontières
justement quand on ne sait pas et que
l'on annonce une telle gravité comme la
cimade l'usaid et le froid de janvier
eh bien on prend des précautions on
ferme les frontières
ce n'est un nouveau succès nos fansites
mesures de protection qui concerne tous
ceux qui sont sur le territoire français
comme les autres
vous allez refusé nous avons demandé
l'achat massif de massy plus une
une campagne sanitaire ça se prépare on
dirait des années un en avant vraiment
vous nous ce que nous avons toujours
proposé une réindustrialisation
l'entreprise nous aurait permis de
produire des masques nous avons toujours
dénoncé la les coupes sombres fait à
l'hôpital et les guérillas matière de
vaccins encore récemment le président de
la république a choisi de refuser le
vaccin russe alors qu'il a montré toute
son efficacité il s'agit donc d'un choix
idéologique qui brise les français de
nombre de nombreuses doses de vaccin et
on ne peut pas dire que le prix ça le
président ne sais pas c'est un choix
purement idéologique qui met en danger
nos compatriotes et qui continue le
mettre en danger notre économie aussi
parce que au plus haut rang du motard et
bien la maladie le virus continue à se
développer et se sont aussi c'est aussi
le monde économique qui en souffrent
puisque depuis plusieurs mois des
commerçants à nouveau les bars les
restaurants depuis bientôt six mois sont
fermés ils sont on arrive bientôt à la
fin de ce débat on a compris votre idée
stéphane ravier bien sûr jean pierre
pont quand on entend stéphane ravier de
dire oui l'a refusé pour l'instant ce
n'est pas un vrai revenu enfin on sent
qu'il est pas il n'est pas enthousiaste
par rapport aux italiens aux allemands
ils voient là il est pas en train de
tendre les bras aux vaccins russe faut
bien le dire on a entendu thierry breton
clément bonne le dire on en aura sans
doute pas besoin bon ça en tant que
médecin c'est important vous êtes député
la république en marche mais vous êtes
aussi médecin on a entendu beaucoup de
médecins sur ce plateau non bien voilà
il faut prendre ton ce combat et on ce
qui marche
oui mais qu'est ce qui marche c'est à
dire que y'a des commentaires des normes
européennes
un regard ou le garder
[Musique]
oui oui non mais encore une fois si vous
l'utilisez qui a des poubelles comme
c'est pas bon ça claque ça on nous vous
prouvera je pense qu'il ya actuellement
des larmes
il faut les respecter c'est vrai
qu'elles sont un peu lentes et loose
mais je pense que c'est un système que
nous avons été de foule le respecter moi
personnellement j'ai passé quatre
week-ends à vacciner 10 dans le nord pas
de calais et personnellement dans ma
patientèle à une centaine des vaccins
très bien tout à fait alors merci jean
pierre pont d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas d'avoir accepté ce débat merci
à vous également stéphane ravier
merci donc quelques instants rester avec
nous nous parlerons des sanctions
financières décrétée à l'encontre de
moscou par washington la russie promet
une réponse n'évita puis direction
vienne les discussions sur le nucléaire
iranien ont repris aujourd'hui dans un
climat tendu malgré une impression
générale positive selon un diplomate
russe
joe biden avait promis durant la
campagne de revenir dans l'accord
dénoncé par son prédécesseur
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
à 20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez
moscou promet des contres sanctions
réponse inévitable selon les termes
employés alors que washington annonce
l'expulsion de diplomates russes après
des cyberattaques et les ingérences dans
l'élection présidentielle qu'elle
attribue à la russie les etats-unis
soutenus dans leur démarche par l'otan
ait lieu une rencontre avec vladimir
poutine est crucial pour stopper
l'escaladé selon joe biden qui maintient
sa position d'organiser un sommet avec
son homologue russe dans les prochains
mois
l'administration d'haydn a clairement
indiqué que les états unis souhaitait
une relation avec la russie qui soit
stable et prévisible
nous ne pensons pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de poursuivre sur une
trajectoire négative
cependant nous avons également été clair
en public et en privé sur le fait que
nous défendrons nos intérêts nationaux
et imposeront un prix à payer aux
actions du gouvernement russe qui
chercheraient à nous nuire
aujourd'hui l'administration maiden
prend des mesures pour imposer un tarif
à la russie pour les actions de son
gouvernement et de ses services de
renseignement contre la souveraineté et
les intérêts des états unis et la russie
a convoqué l'ambassadeur américain à
moscou la tension qui s'accentue
également autour du dossier ukrainien on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
claireaux
croire antoine après les nouvelles
sanctions américaines les autorités
russes annoncent donc une forte riposte
oui tout à fait la diplomatie russe
déplore l' annonce de ces nouvelles
sanctions des sanctions qui visent des
personnes mais aussi des organisations
des sanctions financières donc mais
aussi l'expulsion de diplomates du sol
américain et vous l'avez évoqué
l'ambassadeur américain en poste à
moscou a immédiatement été convoqués au
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
elle dit regretter que washington que
washington continue de souffler le chaud
et le froid
en effet aujourd'hui des nouvelles
sanctions ont été annoncées alors qu'il
y a deux jours joe biden convié vladimir
poutine à une rencontre afin de
normaliser les relations entre les deux
pays je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de maria serrano
nous avons à plusieurs reprises mis en
garde les états unis contre les
conséquences de mesures de confrontation
qui attise dangereusement les tensions
entre nos pays pakokku ce comme nous
l'avons souligné à plusieurs reprises
une telle voie n'est pas dans l'intérêt
des peuples des deux principales
puissances nucléaires qui ont une
responsabilité historique pour le destin
du monde lors de son échange
téléphonique avec le président russe joe
biden a exprimé son intérêt pour la
normalisation des relations américano
russes
mais les actions de son administration
témoigne du contraire
les etats unis ne veulent pas accepter
la réalité objective que le monde est
multipolaire et qu'il exclut l'hégémonie
américaine
en revanche il impose des sanctions
comme un moyen de faire pression et
pratiquer l'ingérence dans nos affaires
intérieures
la porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères a promis donc de
répondre avec force
à ces nouvelles sanctions américaines
elle a également dit regretter que de
nombreux pays occidentaux viennent
soutenir les aventures je cite les
aventures sanglantes de l'ukraine dans
le donbass est justement le dombass il
en sera encore question dans la journée
de demain à l'occasion d'une rencontre
entre emmanuel macron angela merkel mais
aussi le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky et antoine vous vous trouvez
précisément à la frontière avec
l'ukraine non loin de dounia août sujet
de discorde avec les états unis quelle
est la situation sur place sur le
terrain alors j'ai envie de dire qu'il
ya un réel contraste entre le
centre-ville de deux nièces coup nous
nous trouvons en ce moment même et où la
situation est tout à fait normal les
magasins sont ouverts les gens marchent
dans la rue il y a aucun signe extérieur
qu'un conflit se déroule à proximité
immédiate
et pourtant c'est bien le cas cet après
midi nous avons été à tout juste 20 kg
vingtaine de kilomètres du centre de
données est hélas ce n'est plus du tout
la même histoire nous étions dans un
village où les habitants vivent avec la
peur au ventre avec des grenades qui
tombe dans leur jardin des tirs de
snipers qui qui les guette selon les
angles selon certaines rues du village
où ils se trouvent et donc il a
véritablement un contraste entre entre
entre la ville entre le centre ville et
la banlieue tout proche d'ailleurs les
habitants du village nous nous trouvions
cet après midi nous ont fait savoir
qu'en début de soirée et des explosions
avaient retenti à proximité de leurs
habitations
merci antoine claireaux qui se trouve
donc à dos n'y est ce à la frontière
avec l'ukraine merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur la défense de nous
avoir donc tenu au courant de la
situation sur le terrain et pour en
parler nous sommes avec xavier moreau
directeur de strates paul bonsoir xavier
moreau merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
clairement quand on entend antoine
claireaux nous expliquer la situation
sur le terrain quand on l'entend
l'ambassadeur de russie à londres qui a
été convoqué les pays membres de l'otan
qui ont annoncé leur soutien à la
décision de washington de sanctionner la
russie on se dit qu'une escalade est à
craindre
écoutez j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'on
est dans la situation inverse que
généralement avec les occidentaux
plus ils parlent fort - ils ont
l'intention d'agir parce que ce qu'on a
observé aussi ces derniers temps je
c'était je crois il ya deux jours c'est
que l'attaché de presse du président
céline ski madame you lie à wendel a
déclaré que la solution de force pour
reprendre le dans de basses n'était pas
d'actualité
les deux bateaux de guerre américain qui
devait passer le détroit du bosphore
pour rejoindre la mer noire ont
finalement annulé leur passage et il est
clair que les la présence des troupes
russes à la frontière ukrainienne a
coupé l'envi des élites ukrainienne à
commencer par le président téléski de
lancer une opération militaire sur le
dos de bath en tout cas pour l'instant
donc effectivement ce qu'on va continuer
à observer c'est ce qu'a vu et c'est ce
que voit votre journaliste à donetsk
c'est que cette espèce de harcèlement
des populations pour empêcher un retour
à la vie normale et bien qui consiste à
les bombarder envoyé des drones larguer
des grenades et tuer des enfants de 4
ans comme c'est arrivé et il ya une
semaine mais je pense à mon avis que les
que l'escaladé plutôt en train de
diminuer et que si le regarde ailleurs
dans le détail les sanctions que joe
biden a pris contre la russie en gros on
sait tout le monde s'y attendait plus ou
moins et c'est pas bien méchant c'est
pas bien méchant en tout cas le kremlin
juste que de nouvelles sanctions à
contre la russie bat n'allait pas
forcément favorisé l'organisation du
sommet que proposait joe biden à
vladimir poutine
ces sanctions justement ce n'est pas la
première fois
en a déjà qui ont été prononcées en 2014
est ce qu'elles portent leurs fruits en
général à bas pour là je l'avais dit en
février 2015 les sanctions seront
peut-être là une chance énorme qu'à la
russie depuis 1992 et ça a été le cas
donc toutes les sanctions russes et les
contres sanctions qui ont été prises par
la russie ont permis un décollage de la
delà de l'économie russe dans certains
domaines notamment le domaine agricole
mais pas seulement et surtout la menace
d'avoir par exemple l'interdiction du
swift interdictions de visa et
mastercard
et bien tout ça a permis à la russie de
mettre en place son propre système il ya
maintenant un système qui remplace le
swift qui pourrait être à terme
connecter avec la chine justement ça
gagne lavrov en a parlé il n'ya pas
longtemps
la russie veut vraiment sortir du dollar
et vous avez également bien là la carte
mère qui remplace la les visa mastercard
même si il faut perdre le soulignait
visa et mastercard ont déclaré hier ou
aujourd'hui qu'il voulait continuer à
travailler en russie qu'il n'était pas
question de partir donc je pense que ces
sanctions ne font pas grand mal ce qui
est un peu nouveau on peut le dire c'est
que désormais les obligations russes
donc d'état les institutions américaines
ne peuvent pas les acheter sur le marché
primaire n'ont en revanche peuvent aller
les acheter sur les marchés secondaires
ou et c'est sans doute ce qu'elles font
et ce qu'elles feront puisque de toute
manière les institutions américaines
avaient acheté beaucoup moins de
d'obligations russe qu'auparavant donc
je pense que si vous voulez pour que joe
biden puisse organiser une rencontre au
sommet dans un pays tiers avec poutine
comme louis le chouette c'est bien là la
demande vient de gmail
il faut qu'ils donnent du grain à moudre
à ses élites aux élites occidentales qui
attendent non pas une revanche après les
quatre ans de trump mais une vengeance
les voiliers même les néo conservateurs
français ils sont dans un état de rage
poste trump et ils ont besoin ils ont
besoin de co2 qu elle leur donne quelque
chose hebeisen s'est rendu compte d'une
chose c'est qu'en fait il n'a pas plus
de poids sur poutine et sur la russie
que l'on avait trompe et que trump a mis
les sanctions qui ont qui n'ont pas
trouvé un marché sur le stream 2
il a ralenti la la construction du
gazoduc de plus d'un an et demi donc
c'est pas si mal et buydens ne peut pas
faire grand chose de plus
et je me demande si d'ailleurs cette
invitation de vladimir poutine un sommet
encore une fois dans un pays tiers n'est
pas une prise de conscience par une
partie de l'état profond et donc de son
représentant joe biden qu'il est trop
tard que désormais il va falloir
utiliser d'autres moyens que la menace
est là coire scission et qu' il faut
essayer pour de vrai cette fois de faire
un reset avec la russie mais ça eh bien
on va là on va le voir dans les dents
l'espagne tidiane faye est justement un
discours de john dryden qui est annoncé
je pense qu'il faut mettre en parallèle
cette volonté de discuter joe biden et
le fait qu'il doit donner quelque chose
un public néo conservateurs démocrates
américains qui qui qui veut qui veut se
venger de l'avenir poutine le kremlin
qui accuse aujourd'hui de la russie de
bouloire je cite la détruire à la veille
à 1 précise d'un sommet avec le chef
d'état ukrainien c'est une façon quoi de
faire monter la pression d'obtenir des
choses de l'occident écoutez l'ukraine
n'a pas besoin la russie pour
s'autodétruire
ça fait ça fait sept ans que ça dure et
je dirais d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est
ce sur quoi la russie contre la russie
n'a aucun intérêt aujourd'hui à lancer
une offensive contre l'ukraine pourquoi
et bien parce que elle a trouvé en
allemagne un partenaire efficace et
loyal et on le voit notamment dans la
construction de nord stream 2 donc pour
la russie lancer une attaque contre
contre l'ukraine reviendrait à trahir
ses alliés en allemagne et ses alliés
c'est les gens qui sont au pouvoir c'est
monsieur l'achète qui sera peut-être
qu'en dit la chancellerie où c'est
monsieur jodar le président ministres de
bavière qui lui aussi sera peut-être
candidat pour la céder ou cs ou en
allemagne donc ya énormément de députée
soit de la gauche avec die linke soit
des gens de l'alliance pour la pour
l'allemagne qui soutient la position
russe et qui ne comprendraient pas si la
russie gachet c'est ce partenariat qui
pour l'instant fonctionne l'allemagne
pour l'instant résiste aux menaces
joe biden veut nommer un ambassadeur
spécial monsieur amos oz stein pour
directement les menaces et allemagne en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui a servi
les menaces et l'allemagne pour achever
la construction de nord stream ii est
pour l'instant l'allemagne tient bon
donc évidemment la russie n'a aucun
intérêt à lancer une opération contre
l'ukraine en ce moment et simplement
vlademir zielinski à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine a de gros problèmes avec tout
simplement avec ses mauvais résultats
avec le fait qu' il a trahi ses
engagements présidentiels et que
désormais les partis qui caracole en
tête ce sont des partis pro russe qui
l'a lui même sanctionné
il ya deux partis qui sont en train de
percer c'est le parti l'ukraine pour la
vie de monsieur medvedev look qui alors
qu'il est citoyen russe est sous
sanction de l'ukraine c'est ce que
l'ukraine a inventé c'est à dire les
sanctions contre ses propres citoyens et
également anatomy charrie qu'il ya un
parti qui en cas de succès auprès des
jeunes très efficace très avec des
activistes très très motivé et c'est ça
le poème zelensky ces îles il est
intérieure il exactement le même que
celui qui avait son prédécesseur petro
porochenko il doit faire monter la
tension de manière artificielle dans le
bonne base pour couvrir son échec quasi
totale économiques politiques
stratégiques de l'ukraine de kiev
merci xavier moreau directeur de strates
paul de noah vous avoir apporté votre
analyse merci à vous les discussions sur
le nucléaire iranien ont repris à vienne
aujourd'hui objectif le retour des etats
unis dans le traité que donald trump
avait quitté en 2018 les diplomates ont
évoqué une impression positive mais
aussi un climat tendu notamment due à
l'acte il est d'une actualité
mouvementée du nucléaire en iran ces
derniers jours guillemard aussi une
impression générale positive
c'est ce qui est ressorti ce jeudi à
vienne en autriche des deux heures de
réunion relative à l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
nous sommes heureux de voir tout le
monde de retour à vienne prêt à faire
avancer nos discussions
malgré les événements et les
déclarations très difficile de ces
derniers jours
nous travaillons vers le même objectif
le retour des etats-unis dans l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien et sa pleine
mise en oeuvre des événements difficiles
à un euphémisme pour évoquer l'escaladé
des tensions autour du nucléaire iranien
depuis ce week end
à l'origine un acte de sabotage commis
dimanche matin dans l'usiné
d'enrichissement d'uranium de natanz
dans le centre de l'iran or le programme
atomique de téhéran est sa principale
arme diplomatique la république
islamique n'a donc pas tardé à réagir
lorsque vous commettez un crime
nous vous coupons les mains nouveaux
coupons les demain nous coupons l'une
avec les centrifugeuses ir 6 nous
coupons l'autre avec l'enrichissement
d'uranium à 60 % 60 % un taux
d'enrichissement bien plus élevé que les
3 67 % prévus par le traité de vienne et
qui s'approche des 90% nécessaire à la
fabrication d'armes atomiques et qui
suscite de vives inquiétudes
ces annonces iraniennes sont
particulièrement regrettable à un moment
où tous les participants à l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien et les états unis
ont débuté des discussions
substantielles dans l'objectif de
trouver rapidement une solution
diplomatique permettant de revitaliser
et restaurer l'accord la communication
récente dangereuse de l'iran est
contraire à l'esprit constructif et à la
bonne foi de ces discussions
we take nous prenons très au sérieux son
annonces provocatrices d'une intention
de commencer à enrichir l'uranium à 70
concerts dois vous dire que cette mesure
remet en question le sérieux de l'iran
ce qui concerne les pourparlers
nucléaires
si comme le souligne l'impératif de
revenir à une conformité totale avec
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
c'est jack city way le président hassan
rohani c'est lui défendu de toute
attitude belliqueuse
nous avons annoncé dès le début et nous
nous en tenons à ce que nous avons dit
que nos activités nucléaires sont
totalement pacifiques et que nous ne
cherchons pas à fabriquer des bombes
nucléaires
l'objectif des négociations à vienne et
le retour des etats-unis dans l'accord
que donald trump a quitté en 2018 des
pourparlers techniques se poursuivront
dans les prochains jours
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
thierry coville chercheur à l'iris
spécialiste de l'iran bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous une impression
générale de la réunion de jeudi sur le
nucléaire iranien
positive nous dit-on mais qui sera suivi
d'un certain nombre de réunions
informelles à quoi vous le spécialiste
de l'iran vous attendez-vous pour ses
prochaines réunions
je pense qu est important c'est que ces
discussions aient commencé qu'elles se
poursuivent en dépit de toutes les
déclarations
l'iran reste dans l'accord de 2015 s'il
faut pas l'oublier est donc l'objectif
est toujours le même c'est un retour
coordonnée des états unis dans l'accord
techniquement c'est pas très compliqué
il faut que les deux pays se mettre
d'accord pour d'un côté les états unis
lèvent les sanctions qui ont été re
avait imposé par train peut partir de
mai 2018 et que l'iran revienne sur
toutes les mesures qu'ils ont prises à
partir de la mi-2010 9 pour sortir de
l'accord vous détenez pas compliqué ça
n'a pas l'air non plus très simple
l'iran a en tout cas la réclame cette
levée des sanctions
pourquoi ça ne va pas plus vite c'est
fait aussi simple non mais techniquement
j'ai dit c'est pas compliqué
politiquement c'est autre chose
d'un côté vous avez quand même aux états
unis joe biden doit faire face à
beaucoup d'opposition que ce soit dans
le parti républicain même dans son
propre parti démocrate
un stand de groupes qui sont contre
simplement un retour des etats-unis dans
l'accord qui sont contre la levée des
sanctions
donc ça posait ça ne posait pas parce
qu'il a besoin du congrès par rapport il
veut dit doit faire voter son plan de
relance et c'est donc il
en gros il doit faire passer cette
pilule abdon qu'il faut qu'ils prennent
des formes et du côté iranien
c'est pas rien les relations avec les
états unis on va dire ça
l'opposition aux etats unis c'est on est
au coeur idéologique de la république
islamique d'iran donc la république
islamique d'iran peut pas comme ça
montrer qu'elle est d'un coût y tout va
bien que les etats-unis qui en plus en
plus il ya une énorme méfiance vous avez
des etats-unis en iran il faut rappeler
quand même l'iran respecté l'accord les
états unis en sortent sans raison
appartiennent mais 2018 donc il ya eu
déjà il ya cette hostilité nature
q c'est énorme méfiance et le fait que
sur les radicaux au pouvoir en iran donc
et aussi des questions de politique
intérieure en iran mais je répète
techniquement c'est pas très compliqué à
mettre en place et je trouve c'est quand
même très important en dépit de ce que
disent les deux pays bas les ces
discussions commencées et en dépit ce
qui vient de se passer l'iran reste dans
ces discussions c'est ça qui est
important
alors il ya quand même quelques
obstacles avaient dit qu'ils sont avant
tout politiques la décision notamment de
l'iran d'enrichir l'uranium à hauteur de
60%
c'est de nature à inquiéter tout de même
c'est une information qui peut faire
entrave
évidemment tout de suite
et d'ailleurs si l'objectif recherché
par l'iran en parlant de 60%
ils font peur dans le sens on s'approche
des 90 % qui sont la limite technique à
kehl on commence à fabriquer des armes
nucléaires
d'un autre côté il faut quand même
rappeler que cette annonce de l'iran et
vient et vient tout de suite après
l'attaqué terroriste le contrôle les
indh en attente manifestement qui vient
d'israël donc je pense que du côté
iranien
il utilise l'enrichissement d'uranium
comme moyen de pression dans les
négociations
je pense que je veux dire ils sont
toujours autant ces négociations c'est
pour eux c'est une manière de mettre la
pression notamment sur les états unis et
je le répète il faut pas oublier que
s'il avait voulu quitter l'accord il
aurait très bien pu faire le guide
aurait très bien pu décider depuis mai
2018 va être mis en quête l'accord ils y
sont toujours
donc c'est vrai que c'est inquiétant un
compte tenu du fait que le niveau
d'enrichissement était à 3,67 % dans
l'accord de 2015 la is a long 60 % ils
annoncent ils n'ont pas commencé mais je
pensais plutôt une tactique pour mettre
la pression notamment ceux des états
unis pour pour se négocier en tout cas à
san juan il essaie d'être rassurant et
déclare que ses activités nucléaires de
l'iran sont pacifiques à reverser ce que
nous dit lironde depuis des années en
maintenant est ce qu'on peut vraiment le
croire
écoutez pour s'il voulait faire la bombe
du caire pourquoi ils ont signé l'accord
et 2015
je pose une question m je crois qu'en
quand donald trump prend la décision
j'ai déjà dit sur votre antenne 2
sortir de l'accord en mai 2018 je crois
qu'il ya onze rapport aux rapports de
l'agencé internationale d'énergie
atomique qui est chargée de vérifier
l'application d'accords qui certifie qui
en respecte l'accord et l'accord donné
toutes les garanties pour que le
programme nucléaire iranien reste
pacifique jusqu'à la fin de l'accord je
crois qu'ils aient 2025 donc voilà la
réponse est là et l'iran n'a pas quitté
l'accord en dépit du fait qu'elle est la
principale un acteur important que les
états unis à est sortie de l'accord je
répète sans raison et amis remis en
place des sanctions qui ont dévasté
l'économie iranienne donc les rangs et
toujours dans l'accord il s'y tienne
c'est très important pour eux et donc je
pense que si vous voulez faire la bombe
atomique il serait déjà sortis de la
corde je crois d'ailleurs en plus bon
l'agencé internationale d'énergie
atomique disait clients respecter
l'accord je crois qu'elle vient d'avoir
un rapport de toutes les agences de de
sécurité américaines qui pensent qu'à
leur avis alors que l'iran ne cherche
toujours pas à aller vers l' arme
atomique
il utilise je le répète l'enrichissement
d'uranium comme moyen de pression et ce
qu'ils demandent finalement c'est le
retour des etats-unis dans l'accord qui
garantit que le problème nucléaire
iranien est ce si triste au civil merci
beaucoup thierry coville chercheur à
l'iris spécialiste de l'iran d'avoir été
avec nous à voir porter votre analyse
aux etats unis à présent duo baden c'est
face à son premier gros défi celui de la
crise migratoire depuis son élection des
milliers de personnes originaires
d'amérique centrale souhaite entrer sur
le territoire américain une situation
compliquée le président américain qui
avait critiqué la politique de son
prédécesseur les explications de thomas
bonnet à peine élu joe biden doit déjà
gérer une crise migratoire historique
son arrivée au pouvoir a été perçue
comme un signe d'optimisme pour des
milliers d'habitants d'amérique centrale
après une mandature trump marquée par
une forte rigueur en matière
d'immigration
beaucoup pensaient que l'administration
bailon marquerait une rupture s'était
d'ailleurs en filigrane ce qui
ressortait des annonces du candidat by
day est aujourd'hui face à
l'augmentation considérable du nombre
d'arrivées le président démocrate semble
dépassée depuis janvier les etats unis
ont enregistré 30 % d'arrivée
supplémentaire de personnes originaires
d'amérique latine et centrale
rien que pour le mois de mars environ
168 milles personnes ont été prises en
charge par les agents de la patrouille
frontalière américaine à la frontière
entre les etats-unis et le mexique
c'est le chiffre mensuel le plus élevé
depuis 2001 outre le signal envoyé par
l'élection de byden c'est aussi la crise
sanitaire qui explique en partie cet
afflux massif face aux images de
migrants arrivant à la frontière avec
notamment la dangereuse et parfois
tragique traversée du fleuve rio grande
et joe biden joue la carte de la fermeté
le mexique refuse de les revendre
ils disent qu'ils ne les reprendrons pas
chez d'un doute nous sommes en train de
négocier avec le président du mexique
je pense que nous allons assister à un
changement ils devraient tous être
rapatrié tous
rentrez les seules personnes que nous ne
laisserons pas s'installer de l'autre
côté du rio grande
seule et sans aide sont les enfants un
discours qui tranche avec la posture
humaniste affichée par joe biden durant
sa course à la maison blanche
d'ailleurs des associations des deux
réfugiés ne l'ont pas oublié et rappelle
le président américain à ses engagements
en tant que candidat le président joe
biden avait promis d'accueillir 125
mille réfugiés durant sa première année
de mandat
mais au lieu de reconstruire
l'historique programme bipartisans le
nouveau président est en route pour
accueillir le plus faible nombre de
réfugiés depuis la création du programme
contemporain de réinstallation en 1980
pour tenter de répondre à la crise
l'administration américaine envisage une
autre solution verser de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent aux pays d'amérique
centrale pour que leurs gouvernants
dissuade une partie de la population de
choisir l'exode une méthode critiqué
alors que des milliers d'américains sont
également dans des situations précaires
côté républicain on s'engouffre dans
cette première brèche du mandat byden
des sénateurs se sont rendus sur place
long de la frontière profitant de
l'occasion qui leur est offerte d'ouvrir
les hostilités contre le camp démocrate
nous avons également vu un groupe
d'enfants qui venait d'être testés
positifs au co vite 19
le centre de donna à lui seul rapporte
qu environ 10 % des individus qui sont
détenus sont testés positifs au kovy 19
ces taux sont nettement plus élevés que
ceux de la population américaine et
l'administration byden prend des
personnes qui ont été testés positifs et
les enferme dans des caches côte à côte
c'est inhumain c'est mal la crise
migratoire et plus particulièrement le
sort des mineurs isolés et le premier
véritable test pour joe biden des médias
américains rapportent que le sujet est
source de tension dans le camp démocrate
et preuve que la situation est
inconfortable les journalistes sont
tenus à l'écart priés de ne pas se
rendre sur place les médias doivent se
contenter d'imagés officielles ce qui
fait dire un photographe de presse
dans une tribune qu'abidal mène une
politique d'accès 0 à la frontière le
sujet cristallise les critiques de
toutes parts et les sondages montrent
une grande méfiance des américains
envers la politique migratoire de joe
biden probablement gêné aux entournures
locataire de la maison-blanche évite
soigneusement le sujet sur les réseaux
sociaux
ces publications se concentrant très
largement sur le contrôle des armes à
feu et la vaccination reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons la
situation sanitaire avec la france qu'il
franchit ce soir officiellement un cap
funeste nuit des cent mille morts dus
qu'aux vide
la guadeloupe est elle sert à nouveau la
vis face à la recrudescence des cas et
puis nous reviendrons sur l'avancement
du chantier de notre dame de paris deux
ans au fort après l incendie ravageur
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
étaient à risque ou de ce qu'ils
pouvaient supporter il ya énormément de
problèmes en france comment se fait-il
qu'on est les impôts les plus élevés
d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
pole en profiter en 2011 le monde manque
pas un petit peu non ah oui c'est tous
les fromages tous les soucis sont toutes
les les croissants la pâtisserie traits
de caractère des russes qui peuplaient
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylé
fallu les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la
courgerie ans et demi vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas de terreau vaty ressort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la gt pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes hostiles
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse
avaient difficile
[Musique]
21h heure de paris merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 15
avril
nous n'oublierons aucun visage aucun nom
affirme emmanuel macron ce soir la
france qui franchit officiellement un
cap funès celui des cent mille morts dus
qu'aux vide le pays confronté à une
troisième vague qui dure et interrogent
sur la possibilité d'une réouverture à
partir de la mi mai
côté vaccination enseignants et
policiers de plus de 55 ans sont
éligibles dès ce week end mais le
maquereau au chevet de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris ce matin deux ans
jour pour jour après l'incendié ravageur
une visite par don symbolique mais aussi
politique
le chantier de la cathédrale vu par le
président comme une métaphore des
difficultés que le pays est en train de
traverser et délai de reconstruction
d'édifices doivent être tenues tout
comme les promesses de sortie crise
la france recommande à ses
ressortissants de quitter le pakistan un
départ temporaire en raison des menaces
sérieuses contre les français
actuellement dans le pays
cette semaine encore de violentes
manifestations anti hexagonales ont
éclaté en cause des propos d' emmanuel
macron en octobre dernier accusé
d'encourager le blasphème et
l'islamophobie
[Musique]
quelle croissance cette année en france
avec le troisième confinement bercy et
déjà revu ses ambitions à la baisse ce
sera 5 % tout au plus contre 6 %
jusqu'ici alors dans quelle mesure cette
mise à l'arrêt des pans entiers de
l'économie est elle une menace pour la
reprise ne risque-t-elle pas de reléguer
la france en queue de peloton dans la
compétition internationale
des questions auxquelles l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre
[Musique]
emmanuel macron et les ministres réunis
donc en fin d'après midi pour discuter
des protocoles de réouverture
progressive des lieux accueillant du
public avec un objectif ambitieux un
déconfinement mimer les précisions de
beth sheba les protocoles de réouverture
au coeur de cette réunion entre emmanuel
macron et certains de ses ministres
notamment le ministre du travail de
l'économie du tourisme de la santé ou
encore gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur objectif établir le
calendrier chez les protocoles
sanitaires pour la réouverture des
principaux lieux accueillant du public
pendant cette réunion emmanuel macron
annoncé que la réouverture se fera de
manière progressive en respectant un
protocole assez stricte
et dès la première phase la culture sera
là la première phase durera entre deux
et trois semaines et cela fonctionne
bien nous passerons à la deuxième phase
voilà ce qu'a annoncé le chef de l'état
objectif du gouvernement donner de la
cohérence à l'ensemble de ce programme
le gouvernement soit bien respectée à
cette promesse et ce calendrier à savoir
une ouverture à partir de mi-mai c'est
ce qu'avait annoncé le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il avait annoncé
ce troisième reconfirmant pour cela le
gouvernement table bien sûr sur cette
vaccination en l'accélérant la
vaccination qui a déjà commencé en
france jean castex le premier ministre a
annoncé qu'à partir de ce week end les
policiers et les enseignants de plus de
55 ans seront concernés par cette
vaccination
au total ce sont plus de 430 milles
personnels qui seront concernés une
réunion qui intervient alors que la
france a dépassé le cap fatidique des
100 mille morts le chef de l'état
annonçait que personne ne sera oublié je
vous promets je vous propose pardon
d'écouté emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état depuis le début de la pandémie
cent mille françaises et français ont
succombé au virus
nous avons tous une pensée pour leurs
familles leurs proches pour les enfants
qui ont perdu un parent ou un grand
parent les fratries endeuillé les
amitiés faucher et si toute notre
énergie est aujourd'hui tournée vers la
sortie de cette épreuve
nous n'oublierons qu'un visage aucun
plus de cent mille morts donc en france
la france rejoint
ses voisins britanniques et italiens qui
compte 127 milles morts et 115 mille
morts gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement avait même proposé en
conseil des ministres qu'un hommage
national soit organisée est rendu à ces
victimes si certaines familles sont
plutôt pour d'autres sont au contre
notamment à certaines associations qui
demandent à l'heure actuelle que le chef
de l'état emmanuel macron reconnaît sa
responsabilité face à ces nombreux décès
et pendant ce temps la guadeloupe serre
la vis après avoir constaté la semaine
dernière une hausse significative du
nombre de 4 go vide des samedis jusqu'au
9 mai inclus le couvre-feu passe de 22
heures à 19 heures avec fermeture des
restaurants en soirée à ces nouvelles
mesures de restriction et de limitation
des contacts s'ajoute la fermeture des
cinémas théâtres et musées dans les
collèges et lycées un passage en 2011
sera introduit dès lundi de nouvelles
mesures ne sont pas à exclure si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé explique le
préfet de guadeloupe en écoute ci
malheureusement nous constatons que cela
ne suffit pas nous serons obligés de
prendre des mesures complémentaires dès
la semaine prochaine
cela concernera les restaurants à
l'heure des déjeuners et les galeries
commerciales
et pour en parler nous sommes avec harry
durimel maire écologiste de pointe à
pitre bonsoir harry durimel
c'est d'être avec nous à quoi peut-on
attribuer recrudescence des cas la
semaine dernière en guadeloupe comme ça
semblait aller mieux et peut être que
les gens se sont lâchés et peut-être
aussi que l as et une rebond une horreur
une réaction à à une fréquentation peut
être particulièrement dense en dehors
des périodes festives
certains imputent salle à l'ouverture de
l'aéroport c'était pizza au à ceux qui
ont fait la fête on attend là-bas alors
toutes les toutes les suppositions en
cours mais les gens s'interrogent aussi
il y en a même qui expose quelques
doutes quant à la réalité de ses
passions puisque comme vous savez le le
doute envahit les esprits des citoyens
d'un à tous les niveaux je vois même
aussi au niveau national et donc quand
j'aurai du mal à vous dire précisément
la cause de cette recrudescence façon
tout le monde a du mal à expliquer cette
pandémie d'une manière générale donc ne
vous en excuser pas mais tout de même je
ne vous cache pas qu'en préparant cette
interview j'ai découvert qu'en
guadeloupe il y avait quand même encore
des restaurants ouverts aux
manifestement des musées ddd théâtre
vous avez eu une situation relativement
épargnées par rapport à la métropole
effectivement puisque nous vivons
beaucoup plus en plein air les
restaurants beaucoup de terrasses donc
d'aucuns s'interrogent aussi sur la
pertinence des mesures qui consiste à
fermer les restaurants dont encore ça
pousse si autrefois ceux qui croient pas
ce qu'ils n'en ont du mal à se priver
et donc c'est un pays est un archipel où
les gens ont l'habitude de vivre un
extérieur et se dit bon ça semble n'est
pas confiné on n'est pas un les uns sur
les autres et prennent plus de liberté
c'est peut-être comme ça aussi qui aime
beaucoup d'essence car d'aucuns
pourraient penser que comme il
les alizés c'est le vent qui souffle en
chine où comme il fait plus chaud
certains aient envie de se lâcher
probablement si sa médaille cette
différence que vous voyez je pense que
c'est normal si nous sommes informés en
métropole donc c'est normal que que y
ait plus de libertés ici et que en même
temps n'est plus de mal à ce qu'on
traîne à se priver
le préfet a dit ne pas exclure le
confinement cas de nécessité
comment accueil comment la population à
cesser ses propos ça fait comme une
douche froide parce que chacun se
souvient de la période de confinement de
la première vague et c'est vrai que on
était sortis plutôt rabougrie de cette
période de confinement et je descends
chacun appréhende vous savez d'un mois
de l'opi à des problèmes de l'hôpital de
guadeloupe a connu un incendie qui a
laissé des traces et beaucoup de gens
ont perdu confiance dans la les
structures hospitalières et la capacité
à faire face à une réelle croissance de
des malades de l'épidémie chez nous donc
c'est plutôt angoissant à ce qui
s'annonce
mais bon les alors on se dit bien que
peut-être qu'on n'y échappera se confine
alors des élus mais collet c'était mes
collègues notamment gauthier de la
mesure de fermeture des restaurants soit
revue parce que et selon lui on pourrait
manger et on a des restaurants des
loques beaucoup d'entre eux sont au fond
des terrasses d'accord on aussi entre
envie de profiter de ce beau pays de du
plein air mais en même temps avec la
peur au ventre
puisqu'on entend quand même chacun ap
odieux proches chacun connaît quelqu'un
qui a laissé sa vie donc au nom et à
l'angoissé réel mais vous savez on est
un peuple qui a fait preuve de tellement
de résilience on en attend d'entendre en
nappa sitter de cyclone on a vécu à tant
de catastrophes et à tant d'autres oeufs
sur france 2 et se disent que non ça va
ou encore on n'y échappe
waouh frère il fait beau le soleil est
là ils nous protègent non aussi entre le
grand scepticisme aux confins du
complotisme ait aussi envie de continuer
à viviez et on entend quand dans
l'hexagone on en a reçu cent mille morts
non on n'attend pas des fois un avantage
et cette histoire cette réalité et à
bonal du fait de notre statut on attaque
war aussi qu' on n'est pas si à l'abri
que d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
arte france et dans le sillage de la
crise sanitaire et de ces restrictions
l'impact psychologique sur la santé
mentale notamment des enfants et des
adolescents à emmanuel macron annoncé
hier la mise en place d'un forfait de
prise en charge de 10 séances de
psychologues prépayés chez les adultes
la situation inquiète également
évidemment les proportions de français
en étant sûr dépressif a fortement
augmenté depuis le début de la pandémie
près d'un tiers de la population est
concernée une consultation en vue des
assises de la psychiatrie de la santé
mentale devraient débuter très
prochainement et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec leïla ou brahim
docteur en psychologie et psychologues
bonsoir les lao brahim merci d'être
avec nous un mot tout d'abord sur la
mise en place d'un forfait psy pour les
enfants une vraie bonne nouvelle en
selon la société française de pédiatrie
ou un pansement sur une jambe de bois
selon vous bonsoir merci mais cueillir
ce soir effectivement c'est une bonne
nouvelle toute façon il pourra gilles il
ya urgence on a tous compris les
aujourd'hui il faut agir mais intense
mais en gros il faut agir en prenant en
compte notre expérience
donc aujourd'hui on a et on a des
résultats d'études scientifiques sur le
confinement le premier compliment mais
qui voit le jeu en conséquence avec
cette connaissance là mais aussi avec
l'expérience les premières mesures dans
le cadre de chez gepci qui a montré ce
que tous les étudiants bien montré ses
limites notamment une proposition qui
est faite sans vraiment en concertation
avec les professionnels de la santé
mexico dalle est encore une fois cette
proposition lui forfait possible si j'ai
bien compris les sciences rang 10 c à
106 ans encore une fois avec la compagne
du médecin en face on parle approbation
donc effectivement il s'agit
d'accueillir la souffrance de passer aux
urgences
vous devez distance et moi ça
effectivement
mais ça veut dire passer par la
compassion 800 quel médecin
parfois c'est ce que m tout à fait
compris qu est ce que j'ai vécu avec eux
exempts de celle ci voilà il va falloir
voir comment ça se passe pas et que les
psys mais encore une fois aussi c'est de
dire qu'il faut régler tout en glisse et
ans oui donc comme je pense que ça va
poser une limite et cette mission
d'information du petit et de dire enfin
c'est ce que je comprends et beaucoup de
collègues aussi simple et concret c'est
au médecin d'évaluer si la personne
d'enfants ou d'adolescents 1 2 mois de
suivi psychologique
c'est en tout cas ce chèque concerne les
7 à 17 ans vous l'avez constaté
dans votre cabinet avec votre vos
patients c'est un réel besoin il y a
beaucoup de troupes chez ses enfants
même jeune ya moins de résine ans qu'on
pouvait peut-être l'imaginer oui
exactement des mêmes avec la fermeture
des écoles c'est encore encore moins de
contacts sociaux déjà y avait les
activités sportives qui était limitée
des parents me disais ça c'était qu'il
craint pour eux les activités
extrascolaires et maintenant de l'école
donc effectivement c'est encore plus de
contacts sociaux privés pour ses enfants
donc oui forcément là je pense qu'on
arrive à les crises cette tranche d'âge
qui nous montrent des symptômes de films
l'anxieux et ça va jusqu'à la tentative
de suicide
c'est d'être à zappa les tentatives de
suicide était là bien sûr des enfants et
adolescents au tronçon l'approché des
drogués sont au contraire des
problématiques on ait rencontré une
présenter des unités super ça c'est on
va dire plutôt commun dans les services
on accueillait tous les soutiens mais
aujourd'hui la différence c'est une
tentative de suicide du passage à l'acte
ça vient d'où en fait quelqu'un de quoi
s'offrir le plus c'est ses enfants
finalement et bien un peu comme les
adultes un peu comme toute la population
au vu de la limitation des liens sociaux
après il ya aussi une dimension c'est on
va parler de ceux qui ont des contextes
difficiles à la raison et au texte
familiaux très difficile l'école ou des
activités préscolaires constituer une
pause pour eux donc aujourd'hui à vue
cette pause est constamment dans des
contextes familiaux difficiles mais
aussi d'une autre chose parce que je
travaille aussi dans mon établissement
de pondre des personnes en situation de
handicap
ce sont des adolescents à occurrence
avec un autisme par exemple s'en prend
cette situation là les
amusement ils ferment quand il y avait
des cas de contact en temps il ya des
contacts mais aussi des jeunes qui nous
qui ont contracté le virus ou de
variants d'aller en ce moment beaucoup
on faire et enfin le jour au lendemain
donc c'est laisser les familles du jour
au lendemain s'occuper de leurs jeunes
avec la récurrence à un autisme des
appels fribourg au développement et ce
sont des familles qui vont m'appeler me
dire voilà aujourd'hui on lui a dit
qu'il ya des pas qui n'allait pas au
centre et du coup il a développé des
trucs de comportement parce qu'il ne
comprend pas puisque dans l'addiction
effectué ou encore dans le pti sme on
sait que vaut beaucoup d'entre eux il
est question ils sont très attachés et
très difficile pour eux d'appréhender un
champ on parle de ces assises a voulu
par le gouvernement
c'est un c'est un exploit un espoir pour
vous une sorte de ségur pour le mental
des français est ce que c'est encore un
effet d'annoncé où il y aura vraiment
voient là un progrès après cela j'ai pas
qu'on ne peut bien entendu les fans des
vidéos pour le mental des des français
un effet crise voulue par le
gouvernement quelle est votre réaction
oui bien sûr alors c'est un espoir tout
comme bien en ce moment et porter une
proposition pour la création d'un
indécis alors je fais encore le lien
avec ma profession mais parce que
j'espère en tout cas que ce ségur et
toutes ces propositions vont être liés à
notre profession est en vente en liane
prison
c'est à dire dans le débat placé dans le
débat qu'on soit aussi acteurs de tous
ces débats toutes les mesures n'a qui
ont été prises en compte que ce soit
chelsea ou encore aujourd'hui le temps
philippe si nous les pilotes soit
clément c'est une mesure la l1 vivent
elles nous arrivent pas direct qui nous
arrive à travers les médias on découvre
sans un pop-up salsigne grand moment et
on doit après chercher pour mettre en
place ces choses là donc oui j'ai de
l'espoir si vraiment on est tous les
acteurs des parcours de ce mois autour
d'une table pour débattre de tout ça et
voilà mettre en place des choses
ensemble riche ensemble des choses c'est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france les musulmans de france vive le
ramadan à l'heure du couvre-feu et des
restrictions sanitaires malgré les
regrets de ne pas pouvoir célébrer un
moment de retrouvailles des fidèles sur
sont organisées tant dans les mosquées
que sur les réseaux sociaux pour vivre
ce moment de piété un reportage de katia
pique nique pour la deuxième année
consécutive les six millions de
musulmans de france s'apprête à vivre
des célébrations du ramadan entravée par
les restrictions sanitaires
cette année les lieux de culte ne seront
pas fermées mais le couvre-feu de 19
heures prises les musulmans des prières
du soir à la mosquée et des
retrouvailles conviviales de la rupture
du jeûne
comme l'expliquent ses fidèles à cette
année comme lé meilleur sanitaires on
peut inviter personnes par précaution
donc moi cette année je le fais à la
maison ni vu ni connu voilà c'est triste
mais c'est comme ça cette année un
différentiel est énorme
c'est à moi de péter où les gens
fréquentent les mosquées beaucoup plus
que les autres jours et cause de ces
mesures de covin nous sommes privés de
certains prirent importante dans notre
culte il ya deux prières sur cinq cette
année les prières et la rupture du jeûne
eux peuvent se suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux ou encore sur zoom y les
mosquées adopte un protocole sanitaires
strictes
c'est le cas de celle de drancy en
banlieue parisienne pour y croit ça veut
dire interdire de prier ici c'est la
seule derrien infidèle ici ils deuxième
fidèles et là et à presque 2 mètres
entre eux
deuxièmement on n'utilise pas le tapis
un moment pris directement sur tapis et
maintenant on oublie chaque fidèle et
ramène son tapis sa fille qui est plus
de contacts même les abolitions levitte
sauf en cas d'urgence les fidèles
explique se plier aux consignes
redoutant les effets de l'épidémie mais
n'avait qu'une étape et de la prière on
rame la vie commune où les masques
obligatoire fait le jeune à l'entrée la
sortie et on y voit la balle à son
diabète ou bien sûr que oui même les
mamés
il doit tout le temps rappelé que doit
mettre chacun ramène sur le tapis faut
se laver d'abord pour le trail à
distance chacun à sa place à m
franchement avec ce qu'il a on est bien
respectée les parents et d'autres
monstres il en train de suivre ce malgré
sa peine de voir le ramadan confiné
l'imam de drancy hassen chalghoumi
insiste sur la nécessité de se préserver
du virus est quand même il ya de la
tristesse parce qu'elle est maman
défaite pour comme toutes les religions
sont des moments de partage
c'est des moments de partage leur joie
ils partagent leur fait et partagent
leurs expériences maintenant c'est
difficile même entre nous il faut avoir
toujours de cette distance on essaie de
donner cet esprit à nos fidèles que la
vie humaine il plus sacré que n'importe
quel texte dogme prioritaires votre vie
veulent la structure et de la vie de la
personne de sa famille de ses proches
l'iftar ça veut dire la rupture du jeûne
le soir c'est une famille stricte la
prière la nuit a pas des prières
clandestine c'est interdit on peut pas
faire une chose à l'interdiction au nom
du d'une religion on en devoirs des
récompenses de dieu élément important de
ce ramadan la vaccination a été déclarée
licite par certaines instances du culte
musulman comme par la commission d imam
de la grande mosquée de paris
un pas supplémentaire vers un retour à
la normale pour le ramadan de 2022
les retours à paris visite symbolique ce
matin d'emmanuel mettront sur le
chantier de la cathédrale de notre-dame
deux ans jours après un incendie qui a
ravagé l'édifice
le chef de l'état a rendu hommage à tous
ceux qui oeuvrent pour restaurer la
cathédrale évoquant un sentiment de
fierté collective face au travail
accompli robin qu elle une visite avec
une portée politique certaine pour
emmanuel macron on se rendant sur le
chantier de la cathédrale notre dame de
paris
il souhaite mettre en avant un symbole
de la résilience de la france et la
vitalité de ces entreprises
alors que le pays est frappé par la
crise sanitaire du coc vie de 19,1
parallèle complètement assumé par le
président de la république dans un
entretien accordé au parisien ce jeudi
il décrit le chantier de la cathédrale
comme une métaphore des difficultés que
le pays est en train de traverser sur
les échafaudages de notre dame
emmanuel macron s'est adressé aux
ouvriers une prise de parole au sujet du
chantier mais qui aurait très bien pu
s'appliquer aux efforts fournis pour
lutter contre l'épidémie
un message voilà deux
de fierté collective est-ce qu'on a
beaucoup fait en deux ans et on a évité
le pire a remis un immense remerciements
à toutes celles et ceux qui sont
mobilisés par milliers d'enfants et déjà
sur ce chantier de 35 entreprises forêt
de notre france qui est déjà mobilisé
nos apprentis qui est compagnon qui sont
là en permanence
et puis on regarde aussi les trois ans
qui viennent
parce que été dit ou fait avec beaucoup
de rigueur et de professionnalisme mais
il va nous falloir tenir nos objectifs
et donc
sa grande mobilisation de planification
très exigeante et rigoureuse et donc
c'est aussi du volontarisme et d'espoir
en effet la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par emmanuel macron est
largement critiqué au moment où la
france franchit la barre des cent mille
décès liés aux qu'ovide 19 et si
l'aspect symbolique de cette visite
n'est pas contestée par l'opposition
certains députés aimeraient voir
davantage d'implication de la part du
président de la république souhaiterait
qu'ils soient davantage présent
davantage efficaces en matière de
protection sanitaire de notre pays nous
avons tout le débat récurrent sur les
masques sur les vaccins qui n'arrive pas
suffisamment en doses importantes dans
nos vaccinodromes on a ouvert des
centres alors qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de doses aujourd'hui bien
sûr elles vont venir mais par là je
pense qu'il serait non pas préférant
mais qui serait souhaitable que le
président soit au plus près de ses
citoyens au plus près de la crise
sanitaire au plus près de la crise
économique et sociale plutôt que de
faire des visites on va dire symbolique
et d'envisager des réformes qui sont
mortifères comme la réforme sur les
retraites réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui vont être mortifère pour les
françaises et les français avec le
chantier de notre dame
emmanuel macron veut prouver qu'il peut
tenir ses promesses ils l'assurent les
délais de reconstruction seront tenus
quant au général jean louis georgelin
le président de l'établissement public
chargé de reconstruire la cathédrale
il reste plus mesuré il espère que des
offices puisse être célébrée en avril
2000 24 mais estime que les travaux de
reconstruction ne seront pas terminés
avant plusieurs années
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du pakistan la france
recommande à ses ressortissants de
quitter le pays
un départ temporaire en raison des
menaces sérieuses contre les français
actuellement en cause des propos d'
emmanuel macron en octobre dernier et
accusé d'encourager le blasphème et
l'islamophobie et puis ce sera les
liteaux de jacques sapir qui tentera de
répondre à cette question quelle
croissance cette année en france
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé bon nombre de banques
à suivre monsieur c'est quelque chose
qui nous a emmenés dans une catastrophe
en 2007 et en 2008
tous les crédits ficelé goldman sachs et
morgan stanley était évidemment pas au
courant les uns des autres que arte jégo
savez autant d'engagements à droite à
gauche et c'est en principe de l'opacité
de la chose peut l'annoncer dès
maintenant vous aurez des archers gosses
en x 10
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec une jambe en moins 20 autres
combats ont un avis qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
ce
21h30 heure française sous et bienvenue
en direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez la france recommande à ses
ressortissants de quitter le pakistan
un départ temporaire en raison des
menaces sérieuses contre les français
actuellement dans le pays
cette semaine encore de violentes
manifestations anti hexagonales ont
éclaté la raison cette hostilité des
propos d' emmanuel macron en octobre
dernier accusé d'encourager le blasphème
et l'islamophobie
hélène est ce que comme une odeur de
représailles dans l'air au pakistan la
colère gronde alimentée par la
résurgence d'un sentiment anti français
depuis une semaine les affrontements se
multiplient entre la police et les
partisans d'un parti islamiste radicale
le tehrik elle les bikes pakistanais dit
tlpc milliers de partisans protestent
contre l'arrestation de leur chef ce
lundi saad rizvi inculpé au titre de la
loi anti terroriste exige l expulsion
immédiate de l'ambassadeur de france
l'ambassade qui s'inquiètent de cette
nouvelle vague d'animosité dirigée
contre l'hexagone en raison des menaces
sérieuses qui pèsent sur les intérêts
français au pakistan
il est recommandé aux ressortissants
français et aux entreprises françaises
de quitter provisoirement le pays
dans cette campagne dirigée contre la
france
résonnent les mots d' emmanuel macron en
octobre dernier le chef de l'état avait
défendu le droit à la caricature et au
blasphème
au nom de la liberté d'expression suite
à l'assassinât de samuel pâtit ce
professeur tué en octobre dernier en
région parisienne pour avoir montré des
caricatures de mahomet
le prophète de l'islam à ses élèves des
propos qui avaient déclenché des
manifestations au pakistan et dans
plusieurs autres pays musulmans ainsi
que des appels au boycott de produits
français en réaction le premier ministre
pakistanais
imran khan avait convoqué l'ambassadeur
de france accusant emmanuel macron
d'attaqué l'islam et de mener une
campagne islamophobe sous couvert de
liberté d'expression
le président macro aurait pu jouer
l'apaisement et refuser l'espace aux
extrémistes plutôt que de créer une
polarisation une marginalisation
supplémentaires qui conduisent
inévitablement à la radicalisation
il est regrettable qu'il ait choisi
d'encourager l'islamophobie en
s'attaquant à l'islam plutôt qu aux
terroristes qui pratiquent la violence
le tehrik elle les basiques reproche
aujourd'hui au gouvernement pakistanais
de ne pas avoir respecté l'accord qui
aurait été conclu suite à ces
protestations visant à expulser
l'ambassadeur de france en réponse le
parti a de nouveau réclamé en début de
semaine le départ du diplomate bloquant
en partie les deux plus grandes villes
du pays
lahore et karachi ainsi que la capitale
islamabad le gouvernement pakistanais a
annoncé ce mercredi son intention
d'interdire le mouvement tentant cette
fois-ci l'apaisement tout est sous
contrôle
la police et les forces paramilitaires
vont gérer la situation avec la grâce de
dieu
tous les citoyens français vivant au
pakistan sans qu'on sécurité et il n'y a
aucun danger pour eux mais en attendant
les relations entre paris et islamabad
reste très tendue au pakistan où la
question de plus en plus politisée du
blasphème est explosive ridiculiser ou
insulté le prophète mahomet reste
passible de la peine de mort mais pour
en parler nous sommes avec younès
ben el fellah economy spécialiste du
monde arabe
bonsoir younes el fellah merci d'être
avec nous la situation est-elle vraiment
préoccupante pour les français présents
au pakistan
bonsoir je crois que la situation et les
très très compliqué jeu il ya des
menaces qui sont sérieuses d'où la
position de la diplomatie française de
protéger les retire 600 français là bas
qui sont entre 500 et 1000 et et 1000
personnes et en plus les entreprises
françaises parce qu'il faut rappeler
quand même l'existence de 35 grandes
entreprises dans ce pays avec un échange
commercial de 1,5 milliard d'euros et
dont on trouve des des entreprises comme
total sanofi l'oréal sont autant
d'entreprises françaises qui sont
présentes dans ce pays est très
intéressant en matière on va dire de
géopolitique maintenant la campagne qui
est menée contre la france a commencé en
octobre avec une position officielle
parce qu'il faut rappeler que le premier
ministre du pakistan a pris une position
contre le président marc rond en
l'accusant d'islamophobe et de mener une
campagne d'islamophobie systématique
sous le couvert de la liberté
d'expression après on a vu que ce parti
islamiste radical a pris le relais ce
parti qu'il faut rappeler qu'il était
créée en 2015 avec un agent bas
islamiste très radicaliser et ce qui
fait qu'elle a mené une campagne dont
l'objectif était effectivement boycotter
les produits français et deuxièmement le
fait de faire quitter les français du
territoire pakistanais
donc je crois que la décision française
est important dans un point de vue
diplomatique mais elle est également
extrêmement importante pour protéger les
ressortissants français surtout dans un
pays qui a des insuffisances en matière
de sécurité
vous nous dites le problème qui date
depuis octobre dernier pourquoi cela a
empiré maintenant parce que
on entendait des témoignages aujourd'hui
de france aisne unis oman où on voit pas
vraiment plus de dangers qu'il ya
quelques mois qu'est ce qui a changé
donc pourquoi maintenant d'abord les
manifestations menées depuis la semaine
dernière qu'ils étaient des
manifestations très très violente
d'ailleurs y avait deux policiers qui
ont été tuées des intérêts françaises
ont été touchées de plus je crois que la
question que l'échéance qui était donné
par ce parti islamiste a radicalisé qui
était le le 20 avril pour faire quitter
les français du pays c'est une date qui
est très très très sont et combien de
temps il faut aussi rappeler que cette
campagne menée contre la france vient en
même temps de la visite de la cheffe du
chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian à l'inde l'ennemi
historique et géopolitique du pakistan
avec qui la france elle tient maintenant
un partenariat stratégique et elle veut
renforcer son ancrage avec des intérêts
sur le plan militaire est également sur
le plan économique contre l'extension
chinoise dans le lin dans tout ce qui
est de pacifique alors cet après-midi de
partis islamistes et el pais a été
interdite par le gouvernement est ce dû
aux manifestations contre justement la
france ou à l'encontre d'anne et des
policiers qui en ont découlé
non je crois c'est plus par rapport à la
question de deux policiers mais c'est
également une possibilité voilà pour
calmer et apaiser l'opinion l'opinion
publique parce qu'il faut rappeler quand
même c'est vrai que cette partie et les
afficher comme étant un parti politique
a radicalisé mais il y en a d'autres
organisations et partis politiques qui
ont des agendas islamistes le pays il
était un certain moment le berceau des
mouvements radicaliser une forte
présence dans ce dans ce pays la
mouvance des frères musulmans tient
également aussi
une part très importante dans le pays
donc ce qui fait que je crois que la
maintenance qui se passe c'est seulement
le fait de calmer là la situation est
bien évidemment ce sera aussi l'occasion
pour la france de communiquer sur son
image sur son capital d'image dans cette
dans cette région qui était largement au
touché depuis le mois d'octobre dernier
d'abord il y avait une campagne qui tu
es mené par la turquie et erdogan en en
personne l'a maintenant on voit que
d'autres zones où d'autres régions
géographiques notamment le pakistan qui
qui sont qui ont une position contre la
contre la france lundi a été arrêté sa
de riceville le leader du parti
islamiste un tel pays dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est un parti qui
pèse c'est un parti politique important
au pakistan on peut dire que c'est un
parti qui est populiste parce que là le
c'est très simple d'utiliser dans ce
genre de pays la jambe
cela mist pour gagner dé gagner des voix
y mener en quelque sorte des campagnes
contre eux surtout quand il s'agit d'un
pays occidental comme com com comme la
france moi j'essaye de voir la compagne
d'un point de vue plus plus large que ça
parce que je trouve que depuis le mois
d'octobre on était face à une grande de
campagne contre la france d'abord ce à
commencer par le fait de boycotter les
produits français deuxièmement il y
avait des attaques contre la personne du
président de l'as de la delà de la
république et après on a aussi les
intérêts français qui sent qu'ils sont
touchés parce que les ennemis de la
france a parfaitement que la france a
sans vraie capitale c'est sans soft
power sa culture son ouverture
culturelle dans cette danse interrégions
surtout qu'il était connu dans le nom de
arabo musulman par cette ouverture est
d'abord on a vu des positions turques et
là maintenant on voit d'autres pays qui
a réagissent également il y avait un
certain moment les pays du golfe comme
le qatari avait la manie si la
maintenance et c'est le pakistan est
donc si il faut vraiment une réponse
sérieuse
au niveau de quai d'orsay pour
communiquer davantage sur les valeurs de
la france et montrer concrètement la
position la position française mais ce
qui est urgent bien évidemment c'est
protéger les ressortissants français et
les entreprises françaises merci
beaucoup aux lyonnais sa belle fait l'
économie spécialiste du monde arabe
d'avoir été avec nous quelle croissance
cette année en france avec le troisième
confinement bercy et déjà revu ses
ambitions à la baisse sera 5% tout au
plus contre 6% prévus jusqu'ici alors
dans quelle mesure cette mise à l'arrêt
de pans entiers de l'économie étaient
une menace pour la reprise ces vents
contraires ne risque-t-il pas de
reléguer notre pays un peuple au thon
dans la compétition internationale
c'est l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir le nouveau
confinement que l'on vit actuellement à
fait l'effet d'une douche froide qu'elle
va en être le coup et quelles en seront
les conséquences pour l'économie vaste
question bonsoir stéphanie oui
effectivement ce troisième confinement
que le président macro aurait bien voulu
visiblement éviter
eh bien il va coûter cher à coûter cher
à l'économie alors d'abord il va coûter
au niveau des aides 1 que ce soit le
chômage partiel
le fonds de solidarité il va coûter
aussi en termes de croissance parce que
on peut penser que la croissance
française va perdre l'équivalent d'un
point de pib
et puis évidemment il va coûter cher en
perte de revenus fiscaux et donc c'est
trois coups vont s' d'une certaine
manière ce combiné et vont tirer vers le
bas
l'économie française alors j'ai tout
d'abord que va coûter à l'état ce
nouveau confinement
alors bercy a fait des prévisions et on
voit que pour un confinement d'un mois
sais pas s'il ne durera qu'un mois il
paye peut durer et durer plus et bien il
y aurait si on fait l'addition du fonds
de solidarité qui aide les entreprises
et les particuliers
le chômage partiel les exemptions
fiscales
il y aurait à peu près 11 milliards
d'euros qui seraient dépensées pour un
confinement d'un mois évidemment s'il
devait durer plus long et bien
l'addition s'alourdirait jacques le coup
ce n'est pas seulement ce que l'état
dépense mais aussi moins de richesses
produites et donc moins d'impôts oui
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est fini et là on va le voir
on a là aussi des estimations qui ont
été faites par bercy qui ont été faites
par la banque de france et on pense
qu'il y aura donc une perte de
croissance d'environ un point de pipe là
d'ici la fin du mois d'avril et le début
du mois de mai après il ya évidemment
les conséquences de cela et on voit très
bien que les recettes fiscales puisqu'il
ya moins d'activités vont baisser et là
encore ça ajoute l'équivalent de 11
milliards d'euros ce qui fait que
globalement la dette et le déficit
budgétaire pour 2021 devrait monter
encore là aussi de l'équivalent d'un
pour cent du pib' alors jacquin dans ce
contexte comment la france se situe
talents en europe
c'est évidemment un point et déjà il ya
un premier décrochage de la france par
rapport à nos voisins directs européens
alors même si les autres pays ont été
tout autant toucher que nous par exemple
en allemagne on parle d'un reconfirme
ans on parle d'un durcissement des
mesures sanitaires en italie bref et
comme on le voit là sur le graphique est
bien en réalité la france a été un des
pays qui ont été les plus touchées
justement par la crise ducobu alors ce
qui est quand même extrêmement
inquiétant c'est qu'on voit aussi que la
france est un des pays qui se relève le
plus lentement alors que ce soit par
rapport à l'allemagne
évidemment par rapport à la suède mais
même dans le cas du royaume uni le
royaume uni qui est le seul pays qui a
été en fait en dessous de nous au niveau
de la crise du coc vide assez assez
largement
eh bien il va nous rattraper pourquoi
parceque ils ont une politique de
vaccination qui est beaucoup plus
agressive qui est beaucoup plus réussie
il faut le dire que la france est donc
tout cela se conjugue pour faire que la
france en fait se retrouve avec l'italie
tout à fait en queue de peloton en
europe alors jacquin la france est elle
aussi en mauvaise position si on la
compare avec les résultats des autres
pays développés
oui et ça stéphanie c'est quelque chose
qui est aussi extrêmement important
c'est peut-être là où ça se voit de la
manière la plus nette il voulait ce
risque de déclassement qui était un 2e
des classements cette fois ci plus avec
nos voisins européens mais avec les
grands pays développés
alors pourquoi il n'y a pas que la cause
de lakovic bien sûr l'aco vide a joué
très largement
mais il ya aussi une mauvaise gestion de
la crise sanitaire et il y a bien
entendu
l'absence des plans de relance alors on
voit là il ya trois problèmes qui se
posent le premier problème ça a été la
désindustrialisation de la france
l'économie française est aujourd'hui
très largement une économie de services
et c'est ce qui explique que le choc de
la queue vide et été plus brutal pour
nous par exemple que pour les états unis
évidemment pour le japon pour la russie
pour l'accord était un concert c'est un
premier point
le deuxième point évidemment ce sont des
politiques sanitaires qui n'ont pas été
optimale il faut bien le dire nos
politiques sanitaires alors bombe
nous avons fait peut-être un peu moins
de bêtises que des pays comme les etats
unis ou comme le brésil mais nous
n'avons pas non plus réussi réellement
les choses et de ce point de vue là le
japon et la corée s'en tire nettement
mieux que nous et puis il ya un
troisième point qui est encore plus
important c'est les mesures de relance
et on voit là que les mesures de relance
que ce soit celles qui ont été prises au
niveau européen où que ce soit celles
qui sont prises à l'échelon français
reste très en deçà de ce qui est fait
alors que ce soit en allemagne
que ce soit aux états unis en
particulier donc c'est pour ça qu'on
peut parler d'un risque de déclassement
par rapport aux grandes puissances alors
jeanne vous aviez aussi parlé dans une
précédente émission du retard que l'on
serait en train de prendre avec l'asie
oui tout à fait et là encore si vous
voulez il ya des choses qui sont très
inquiétantes
alors bien sûr il ya le cas de la chine
qui a connu une virée une réduction de
sa croissance mais qui n'est pas rentré
en récession en 2020 tout comme le
vietnam
mais si on regarde là encore ce
graphique on voit que même si ces pays
ont un niveau de richesse par habitant
qui est inférieur à celui de la france
bon ce qui est pratiquement le cas de
toutes ces pays
malgré tout la croissance
alors qui est attendu en 2021 mais
encore plus celle qui est attendu pour
2022 2023 ou 2024 va les propulser très
au delà de du niveau que la france
pourrait atteindre est donc là encore il
ya un troisième type de décrochage alors
qu'ils n'affectent pas que la france qui
affectera aussi les pays de l'union
européenne par rapport à ce qui va
devenir maintenant de manière tout à
fait évidente
le pôle de croissance du monde c'est à
dire
l'asie orientale et l'extrême orient de
la manière la plus large alors serait
justement des prévisions de croissance
pour 2021 en france est ce que ce sera
le dernier
il faut l'espérer mais ce n'est
malheureusement pas sûr
on voit très bien d'ailleurs comment
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
détermine d'une certaine manière
l'évolution de la situation économique
si jamais il devait y avoir un quatrième
confinement les conséquences en seraient
tout à fait eu tout à fait dramatique et
on voit aussi à quel point la politique
de vaccination joue un rôle très
important pour la reprise dans les pays
qui ont été très touchés par l'épidémie
et de ce point de vue là on ne peut que
regretter le retard qui a été pris au
niveau français et au niveau européen
d'une certaine manière parce que la deux
de ce point de vue là nous ne faisons
à pire que les autres pays de l'union
européenne mais nous faisons très
nettement moins bien que le royaume uni
ou que les états unis a donc si je
comprends bien jacques on est loin
d'être tiré d'affaires hélas oui hélas
oui c'est vraiment là une question qui
est extrêmement importante
la france a été particulièrement touchée
par cette crise je vous le dis parce que
nous payons d'une certaine manière le
prix de 30 années de
désindustrialisation et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'économie française a été
si particulièrement touchées en
particulier si on la compare par exemple
avec l'allemagne qui a été moins qu'ils
aient été moins touchée alors qu'elle
subit désormais le même niveau de crise
sanitaire que nous alors que la russie
aussi qui a été nettement moins touché
que nous donc ça c'est le premier point
une politique sanitaire qui n'est pas
l'une des meilleures
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire on peut
même dire que là on a été mauvais dans
toute une série de questions
et puis surtout cette absence des plans
de relance ou dix ans cette faiblesse
des plans de relance qui risque de
retarder le redémarrage de l'économie
française et ce sont ces trois raisons
d'une certaine manière qui me sont
craindre un décrochage de l'économie
française que ce soit en europe que ce
soit par rapport aux grands pays
développés où que ce soit par rapport à
ce qu'on appelle les pays de l'asie
émergente et bien nous voilà prévenus
jacques merci pour cette analyse et à la
semaine prochaine
et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera dans quelques
e minute
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs établissements bancaires
utilisées les faits